how're we doing with those flyers miss
Kraus
Iko by rory by Mickey by Moe by Nelson
by Hannah by test bye bye Casper hey
what do you think it a singing
competition just think your neighbor the
the grocery store manager that got that
chicken right there everyone in the city
gets a shot at being a store live on my
stage man come my lady
come come my lady you're my butterfly
but oh my gosh like ooh okay oh yes I'm
fine thank you
how are you and cue the crazy old lizard
good morning mr. moon I got Judith from
the bank on line two
actually I'm gonna have to call her back
my theaters been going through some
pretty rough times
so what do I do the car wash no my next
show is gonna be drumroll please a
singing competition who wants to see
another one of those everyone your
neighbor the the grocery store manager
that got that chicken right there real
talent from real life
that's what audience is one and I'm
gonna get a tool do you ever feel feel
so paper my mommy Merman would you
please tell them what a good singer I am
oh yeah you were great honey by the way
the bathroom sink is blocked again by
honey in your mom
could you ever be really close to me
Johnny you were supposed to be keeping a
lookout sorry day to you if I had a
voice like Mina's I'd be a superstar by
now just singing oh yeah sure he
wouldn't grandmother now blow out your
candles hmm how we do with those flyers
miss Carly
this will be the biggest hit show this
city has ever seen everyone gets a shot
at being a store live on my stage I'm
here win that prize it's mine your home
see you're really funny look in that's
alright cuz I get oh my gosh look at her
butt oh my gosh look at her are you okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you how are you
this is it folks you better be ready to
work harder than you've ever worked in
your lives
yes that was dearie bed got some shows a
final design the fire went out a long
time ago you are not gonna believe what
I did today
but I don't want to be in your game I
wanna be a singer how did I end up with
a son part you got it now the show is
not gonna save your theater maybe it's
time to move on you know how much this
means to us just you thanks it's about
to throb with major piggy power
you know what's great about hitting rock
bottom there's only one way left to go
and that's
Oh
DiBiase
just bleeding in Aisle 6 that was
awesome
if I feel that I could be sudden when I
would say the things I want to say to
you were supposed to be keeping on okay
sorry time my theaters been going
through some pretty rough times lately
so what do I do
quit no my next show is gonna be
drumroll please
a singing competition I just think your
neighbor
the grocery store manager that that
chicken right there real talent from
real life
learnin would you please tell them what
a good singer I am oh yeah you were
great honey
by the way the bathroom sink is blocked
again I'm here to win that prize it's
mine everyone in the city gets a shot at
being a star on my stage
I'll come my lady you're my butterfly
like the wheel right like boom oh my
gosh look at her butt you okay yes I'm
fine thank you how are you
people say you're Humpty you're really
funny looking the show is not gonna save
your theater maybe it's time to just
move on come on you know how much this
means to us you can't just sing it you
got to show the file design the fire
went out a long time ago you are not
gonna believe what I did today I am lost
I am and I don't just don't want to be
in the gang I want to be a singer how
did I end up with a son like you get you
up 9:00 wait okay the money I promised I
could really use some extra piano
lessons yes that was very bad a defining
moment in all of our lives we're going
to be spicy No yeah
don't let fear stop you can doing the
thing you love you know what's great
about hitting rock bottom there's only
one way left to go and that
Singh
Oh
VVIP
Hanabi drumroll please a singing
competition
who wants to see another one of those
everyone your neighbor the the grocery
store manager that that that chicken